humor ist nicht allein harvard-professor
abram loeb und sein kollege armee sie
haben jetzt ein weiteres interstellare
objekt gefunden
das objekt war allerdings sehr klein und
verglühte in unserer atmosphäre
humor ist ja ein extrem seltsames objekt
er beim löw hält es für möglich dass es
sich um ein licht segel einer fremden
zivilisationen handelt was hat es mit
dem neuen objekt auf wichtig zum science
fiction heute mit ronny von raum zeit
lockt der zukunft ja danke christoph
auch bei uns gibt es regelmäßig
faszinieren des seins videos abonniert
unseren kanal nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts herzlich willkommen er machte
januar 2014 trat ein seltsames objekt in
die erdatmosphäre ein
das beinhaltet eine studie die von
harvard-professor loeb und seinen
kollegen armin ist die reihe
veröffentlicht wurde
nach dem humor ereignis durchforsten sie
den cms- katalog- hier sind alle objekte
erfasst also asteroiden meteoriten
weltraumschrott die in die erdatmosphäre
eindringen können am 8 januar 2014 wurde
ein seltsames objekt registriert
allerdings kümmerte sich die forschung
zunächst nicht darum es trat in die
erdatmosphäre ein und verglühte über den
südwestlichen pazifik jetzt ging lob und
sei die datenbank durch und stießen auf
dieses merkwürdige objekt es verhielt
sich nämlich anders als alle anderen
meteoriten zur erklärung als meteoriten
werden im gegensatz zu asteroiden
kleinere objekte bezeichnet sie
verglühen meist vollständig in der
erdatmosphäre
dieses objekt hatte einen durchmesser
von etwa 45 cm und flog mit einer
außerordentlich hohen geschwindigkeit
die forscher berechneten geschwindigkeit
und flugbahn und kamen zu einem
spektakulären ergebnis die
geschwindigkeit des objektes war so hoch
dass die gravitation der sonne quasi
keinen einfluss auf die flugbahn hatte
das ist aber laut löw und sie rein nur
möglich wenn das objekt aus einem
fremden planeten system oder aus der
umgebung eines sterns in unserer galaxis
stammt also nicht aus unserem
sonnensystem war ein zweites intersolar
das objekt durchqueren also doch
vielmehr interstellare objekte unser
sonnensystem als bisher gedacht die
forscher schlagen jetzt eine neue
methode vor um solche objekte zu
untersuchen beim eintritt in die
erdatmosphäre
wenn die interstellare objekte
verglühenden sollte das spektrum der
verbrennung untersucht werden um die
zusammensetzung zu
das könnte wirklich bahnbrechende
ergebnisse liefern denn so können wir
erfahren aus welchen elementen und
molekülen andere sternsysteme und vor
allem deren planeten zusammengesetzt
sind werden jetzt demnächst noch mehr
solche objekte entdeckt astrophysikerin
sind sich noch nicht sicher das ergebnis
interessant doch es basiert lediglich
auf den messwerten eines einzelnen
ereignisses so der astronomen eric
mamajew von der nasa jpl in den science
news
es wird also spannend ob sich die these
von loeb und 2 bestätigt und ob wir es
hier mit einem zweiten interstellaren
objekt zu tun haben und ob die erde
tatsächlich viel öfter als bisher
angenommen solchen objekten begegnet bzw
sie unsere bahn kreuzen in diesem sinne
42 ja vielen dank ronny so und wer noch
nicht raumzeit block der zukunft
abonniert hat macht es spätestens jetzt
hamma themen hammer recherchiert hammer
videos wie zb schwarzes loch gegen erde
was würde passieren unbedingt
draufklicken anschauen und natürlich
raum zeit lockt der zukunft abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran